ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues au gré de nos
déplacements dans nos circonscriptions
une chose est certaine pour nos élus du
bloc communal l'inquiétude est palpable
elle est car les dépenses contraintes
des mairies s'envolent littéralement
cela peut vous paraître trivial madame
la ministre mais il faut bien que les
villes chauffent et éclairent leurs
équipements publics sur mon territoire
pour le moment métropole cela représente
4,5 millions d'euros de sur cours rien
que pour l'énergie
il n'est pas inutile de rappeler que nos
communes fournissent la nourriture des
restaurants scolaires est construisent
aux rénove leur bâti afin d'éviter
d'éviter qu'il ne tombe en décrépitude
pourtant ce sont précisément toutes ces
dépenses liées au fonctionnement du
quotidien qui sont en aide hausse à
cause de l'inflation galopante des
matières premières
on sait déjà que pour la seule année
2022 elles vont globalement grimper de
15% pour les communes
je rappelle que chaque année les
communes doivent équilibrer leur budget
c'est cette obligation d'équilibre qui
oblige certains maires à se demander
s'ils pourront boucler leur budget 2023
sans être contraint de fermer des
services publics
dans ce contexte que fait l'état
clairement pas assez
pour une aide réellement efficiente la
DGF doit faire l'objet d'une
revalorisation à hauteur de l'inflation
je défendrai cette mesure avec mon
groupe lors de l'examen du prochain PLF
ce n'est pas la maigre rallonge de 320
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
bouchera le trou dans la raquette de la
facture énergétique du bloc communal
car je le rappelle il reste toujours
près de 900 millions d'euros non comblé
après l'aide de l'État
si nous en sommes à lutter bec et ongles
lors des débats budgétaires pour obtenir
plus de moyens c'est parce que vous avez
placé nos collectivités dans une
subjective dépendance à l'état et ce en
rognant depuis 6 ans sur le autonomie
financier
vous avez supprimé la majeure partie des
impôts dont elle percevait les recettes
et pouvait moduler les taux
par vos réformes ou siphonner de manière
systémique les recettes plaçons ainsi de
fait les communes sous perfusion
dotation que vous pouvez moduler de
façon discrétionnaire
je le dis sans emballage ce mode
opératoire est insupportable pour la
démocratie de proximité qui œuvrent au
quotidien au sein du bloc communal
en croire les déclarations récentes de
Bruno Le Maire cela ne semble pas aller
en s'améliorant
interrogé sur la gestion financière des
communes en difficulté il a déclaré en
septembre dernier je cite
vous avez des collectivités bien gérées
et d'autres qui sont moins bien gérés
ces dernières ne pourront pas se
prévaloir de l'aide de l'État
cette déclaration trace les contours de
vos malnés pacte de confiance déjà
rejetées à l'Assemblée nationale dans
votre projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques bien que celle-ci
semble avoir peu de chance d'être voté
car rappelons vous êtes aujourd'hui
minoritaire
une chose est certain et certaines vous
êtes animé par une volonté d'entrer dans
une relation transactionnelle avec les
collectivités territoriales voire même
dans personnaliser ses relations avec
l'État
j'en appelle à tous les bancs de cette
hémicycle un grand débat doit être mené
sur une refonte idéologique fondant la
relation état collectivité territoriale
ce débat doit sortir des contingences
matériels et budgétaires et doit être
d'une ampleur supérieure il doit être
interrogé notre rapport à l'impôt local
et la fonction démocratique que
représente la possibilité que ce dernier
puisse être voté et levés par nos élus
locaux
si rien n'est fait alors le gouvernement
accélérera encore la mise sous tutelle
budgétaire des collectivités
territoriales obligeant nos
collectivités à devoir à l'avenir
négocier chaque ligne budgétaire et cela
je le redis n'est ni acceptable ni
supportable